لكن كل المحتوى
لدينا في مديري الخلط بين خطة طن
الشابة تنتهي وفاة نجل آدم و
hd 2 روس
[موسيقى]
lavrov أنطاليا داك وهمهمة الابتدائية
الذي أذهب رولدان واتهمهم الخدين
d y هو الصحيح 1000 أو وقح معهم 3q
ليفادا مثل الألواح من كوخ على
غير ضار
المكسرات باكان أنطاليا مثل هذا النبات
والإدمان على الفوز كلها أمهات
المعلم والخدود د خلف أسوارها
مع هذا ما قبل الطوفان كنت تأكل شكل جديد
السحر بدون والعمل
[موسيقى]
إذا كان الأتراك razh بها والكرتون bardugo
ستجد نفسك hjalmara sami mundindel argali
الفيروس أحبك إلا موناد ليروسيك
فلاديمير بوتين في أكادو عيدر أوليا
متحف الأتراك عليان هو مثل هذه المحنة لساتا الأورال
إنه أمر صريح أيضًا أن توقعاتنا
المفاوضات لم تتحقق ، لكننا
آمل أن أتمكن من ذلك في المرة القادمة
اتخاذ خطوة كبيرة إلى الأمام
وصل مع مجموعة كبيرة من مكتوبة
المستندات ، لقد اتخذنا بالفعل ملفًا محددًا
الاتفاقات
المشاريع والمقترحات و
يأمل أن اليوم من حيث هؤلاء
النقاط التي يبدو أنها بالفعل
المتفق عليها من حيث المبدأ سيكون ذلك ممكنا
التوقيع على الأقل على البروتوكول
الجانب الأوكراني كل هذه الوثائق
اتخذت للدراسة
سنناقش الحديث سنكون في الحقول
أرفين يتحدث حتى يعرفه
اسمحوا لي أن أقول على شعبنا
أرى أنني أعتقد أن معظم بلدي
يأكل المزيد من الجلد يوم القتال
التاريخ dexpot بالنسبة لنا جميلة بقوة
الفقاعة لا تزال الضامن لمياهنا ، عقلي الرصاص
أو
[موسيقى]